[Music]
what can I do about my husband that
degrades the little me and cusses me out
specifically to me but also in front of
my four-year-old daughter get out I've
been really nervous cuz it wasn't an
easy question to ask and I appreciate
you saying that I'm both sorry and not
sorry that I've got such a visceral
[Music]
response what up what up this is John
with the Dr John delone show and I'm
about 750 Mig of caffeine into today and
we're happy to have you on this show we
talk about your mental health clearly
not your uh metabolic health because I
am pretty Juiced to the gills today but
we talk about your mental health and
your emotional health and your marriage
and your kids and whatever you got going
on in your
life we got a studio audience out here
and there's a beautiful little girl
waving good to see you um on today's
show we're going to talk about any
number of things things and I really
never know what's coming because today
the show is made up of callers just like
you moms dads brothers sisters
grandparents kids going through life
doing life in real time struggling with
real stuff if you want to be a caller on
the show you want to call in um you are
going to be having a private
conversation in front of millions of
people but if you want to be on the show
give me a buzz at 1844 693 3291 it's
1844 693 3291 or go to John dooney.com
SL ask
and when does this episode come out
21st the 13th 13th oh because it says
publish date 13th yeah you it's time you
learn the lingo you guys in your numbers
back there I know in our all of our
fancy lingo all right if they haven't
sold out by the time this show airs
which they may have if they haven't sold
out um questions for humans are out the
Christmas deck sells out every year um
but we're going to do a couple right now
yes let's party all right are the
holidays more magical or more stressful
for you oh man um you go
first I I yes I think that's the answer
yes they're stressful um how much is
stress is self-imposed and how much of
it is 99.9% of it is self-imposed
because if we're talking Christmas we
don't travel um I follow my parents rule
which was my kids spend every Christmas
in our home if you want to come visit
great you're welcome but I spend every
Christmas in my home growing up and our
kids have done the same so we don't even
travel it's any stress is self-imposed
by me of we have to do all of these
things you know we have to do the
cookies and it has to be this and it has
to be this and and because I'm a bit of
a control freak stop it really I know
it's everything has to be just right
I've learned to let a lot of that go
over the past few years to make it less
stressful you saw Frozen one and you're
like that's a great idea um yeah that's
exactly how that went uh but um a lot of
so why on behalf of people everywhere
why do you do that to
yourself
um I think it's be it's
a I'm big on
traditions and this is the ones my
family has so this is the ones we're
going to do and trying to bring Roberts
in we have to do all of the things
because we only do them you know all the
different things because we only do them
once a year and then you know last year
life blew up on Christmas Eve and I was
like oh clearly we're not doing anything
so this year there's a lot of those
things we're like we're letting those go
huh so
I man it's not a fair question for me to
answer
because I think that I traffic in magic
with most of my life and my wife
traffics in reality and so I can imagine
we have very different answers to this
that it's more stressful because there's
packing and traveling and I tend
to um
not so much live in reality sometimes
I've never seen that I I know um we'll
just get there when we get there we'll
have tons of fun and if we don't have a
hotel it's fine let's figure it how we
get there if we have not had a family
adventure we all slept in the car yet in
another state right so um for me it's
just all magic and for I think for my
wife and those who orbit me it maybe is
not quite so magical and so I think
that's where the balance happens right I
I try to take on some stress and I think
I try to give some some um provide magic
we do a couple of different experiences
now like there's a a light thing here at
the our Zoo does this light thing this
um it's amazing and so we've started
doing more of those things and that's
one reason we decorate a little earlier
and it's just so that when we come back
from Thanksgiving it's not like go go go
it's like no wait we're gonna back it up
a week and then we could just kind of
ease into it and that that helps a lot
with me but to the family hey y'all
let's back that thing up cuz if you did
that'd be
incredible actually I probably have
before all right let's do another one
all right hold on I think I think a good
thing going forward is if you answer
that question it's just pure magic
you're probably not helping around the
house enough right it's stressful for
somebody yes and if you're like it's so
stressful I want to challenge you to ask
yourself what are ways you could make it
not so stressful and what you can let go
of yes yeah and not hold back anymore
just let it go cuz whatever you're
making stressful is pretty much in your
own mind I often think that and if
people are adding stress it may be the
season two cut them out yeah I was gonna
do the same thing with hand motions but
I decid not to okay what's another one
all right this is an easy one for me
which Christmas song and I know your
answer too would you pay $67 to never
hear
again I would pay
$670 to never hear little Dr little Dr
boy for you yeah you hate that song you
know why cuz the Antichrist wrote it as
he fell from heaven down to the pits of
hell he was like I've got one more curse
to leave Humanity okay what about the um
the Bing Crosby uh will shaking his head
you're literally the best guitarist I
know in person and the song is played
with a snare drum what about the [__]
Crosby David Bowie version everybody
keeps sending me that oh my God it's so
good that is like shining up a like a
car without it doesn't run anymore with
dog chaa it's just like you can't polish
that thing up man it's so good love that
one if maybe if like panta did like a
staccato
like then I could get behind it pro may
maybe maybe I just anybody like guys
imagine will somebody rolls into a band
practice like guys I got a new tune no
drums no Bass Just snare and everyone's
like oh yeah let's let it rip come on
anyway peruma pum pum me and my bum my
drum go ahead what about you Mary did
you know oh yeah you hate Mary that no
she knew it's in the Bible the angel
told her it's a whole thing he came and
told
her yes she knew we know
that I just annoys the ever living crap
out of me but some I I've seen it on the
internets people get pregnant they're
like I had no
idea yes because an Ang didn't come down
from heaven and tell them what happened
and you're giving birth to the Son of
God I mean it's yes she knew
heyo if that song we need to make a if
that song had just a mash up yes no 100%
my son does stuff like that he does
music stuff I'm gonna have him work on
this he needs to to bring the thunder on
that one yeah snare only no nothing with
a melody in it it just Mary Did You Know
over and over married did you know and
nothing what is that I've seen that on
on the internets like nothing says oh
that guy's going to grow up to be a man
that a woman just gave birth and a
little boy's like oh I know what she
needs hitting a drum yeah really that's
by the way as you know when you any new
moms in your life that's not what they
need no they don't need a new drum
casseroles clean the house come hold the
baby so they can sleep they do not need
a drum
solo let's go down the row ad to row ads
to talk to Nikki in Knoxville Tennessee
what's up
Nikki hey how are you I I mean literally
couldn't be better that's probably a
little bit of exaggeration but I'm doing
great how about
you I'm doing good now Mary Mary did you
know is never going to be the same to me
again because she knew right yeah right
and I never thought of it that way so
now ceelo's version was one of my
favorites not
anymore okay all right I was I get us
just get us derailed all right go for it
so what's
up so um how can I what can I do about
my husband that degrades Bel little me
and cusses me out specifically to me but
also in front of my four-year-old
daughter get
out yeah I know it was a really I've
been really nervous because it wasn't an
easy question to ask yeah and I
appreciate you saying that and I'm I I
I'm both sorry and not sorry that I've
got such a visceral response to that
um that is either he goes or you go um
and it with since there's a little one
it's it's best if he goes and yall need
to take a 30-day separation is this
pervasive does this happen all the
time not all of the time I feel like
it'll be like a month that's really good
maybe up till two months and then it
will just then it will happen and then
it will be a week of not talking him
giving me the silent treatment um um it
it always gets flipped so like it's my
fault you know or it do I wouldn't have
acted that way if you didn't do the CU
he married a seven-year-old I literally
had that conversation with a with my
seven-year-old the other day when she
was like my my her brother he made me
and I stopped and said no he didn't no
he didn't yep your feelings feel big and
it feels like you can't control them and
that's what my job is is to teach you
and help you and walk alongside you but
he didn't make you do anything he make
you hit him he didn't make you what
right and you you're made to a
seven-year-old and a humongous male body
that is such a coward he decides to yell
and scream at his wife in front of his
child yeah I mean that's the height of
cowardice the only the only step further
is to hit somebody um in that situation
has he ever been violent with you no he
hasn't been violent no that luckily the
two things I always said is I can never
imagine him cheating or laying hands on
me yeah but you yeah you couldn't have
imagined him talking to you this way
either yeah yeah it's true right what in
the world sets him
off honestly I feel like it could be I
mean it could be any number of things
even something is little like last week
where um in my field of work I'll
there's certain times where I have to
train people and I'll be gone a little
bit more often and keep in mind like I'm
the bread winner I I have I have to you
know and so I'll tell him like I and I
know he's going to get mad so I have to
gear up to it like listen this week I'm
going to work five days instead of my
normal three or four so um like be
prepared you know why in the world would
he get I'm not I promise I'm not I'm not
raising my voice at you I would hug you
if you're here I know I know why in the
world when you're the bread winner does
he get mad a when you're going to serve
somebody and teach them and train them
and be you're going to make more money
why do it cut into video game
time yeah right yeah it's well I I
that's the thing that I have such a hard
time with because it'll be like before
when I wasn't training people he's like
you're not working to your full capacity
you do so good at training people I
don't know why you do or why you don't
and then I do and it it's only you you
just prioritize your job your job's only
when that's important I have to be the
one to take care of the daughter and all
that you know it's so I feel like no
matter what I do it's wrong there you go
you know why cuz he's moving the he's
moving the Finish Line because this has
zero to do with
you this has to do with whatever he's
going through or working through he's
unwilling to do it unable to do it
whatever I don't care what I'm looking
at is the resulting Behavior and the
resulting behavior is you live with a
seven-year-old in the body of a grown
man and he doesn't get to talk to you
that way he doesn't get to talk that way
in front of your
kid yeah who is this guy like don't I
don't know his name but like tell me
about him what makes him so great and
wonderful that he can just spit on his
wife like
this I
well I don't know's he's a big muscular
dude he takes a lot of pride in his
Fitness and he's I mean I guess when I
listen to your podcast you'd probably
describe him as self-righteous when I
describe him you know this way like he's
always always acts like he's super busy
but really doesn't have a whole lot to
do or
um I I don't know he's he's always has
to be the leader he always Prides
himself on being such a
man but then he treats me like this and
it's like well you want to pride
yourself on being a man then act like
one you know it's one of the least
masculine things a man can do is to
treat those he has been charged and not
only charged but committed he opted in
to this relationship with you he opted
into Parenthood by Sleeping with you and
to op to those you have opted in to love
and honor and take care of the least
masculine thing you can do is use them
to wipe your boots
off to use to to do anything other than
be out in the marketplace trying to make
your community better earn a living for
your
family sure go to the gym that's an
important part of it but I did my gym
work this morning and I worked out hard
before anybody was
up yeah
right yeah and well and and there's like
a few other pieces to it too where I'm
like man I kept thinking if maybe if he
just does one this one thing it'll be
better this thing like he's been seeing
a counselor now for a year and a half we
did marital counseling for a year he he
runs a Men's
Ministry oh good God it's things like
that where I'm like man like I like he's
the last person that should be running a
Ministry for
men and that's my thing but if I ever
said that of course I would be
like it would be if you ever said hey
your behavior at home and the way you
treat me and our daughter doesn't align
with the lessons you're teaching these
men he would respond by cursing and
yelling
and right he would just he would exactly
roll into what you
said MH I've probably let it slip before
to be honest you know there's like a
saying oh oh I have said before I wish
that some of the guys from your group
could see the way that you speak to me
because they wouldn't be attending
anymore you know and and what's his
response to
that his typical responses well he'll
either go to the most extreme and say
something like I'm how about I be how
about I actually start to be a terrible
husband so you could see what it's like
to have a hard life or or you're such a
victim you always have a victim
mentality and all right so here's here's
the path okay I can't make you do what
I'm about to say and I've only got to
talk to you for a few minutes and so I
don't even know if it's the right thing
but based on what you've told me if you
were my sister or you were my like one
of my close
friends if you were a female cooworker
of mine and you said what youve just
told me I would say you're you're right
I'm done being a
victim nobody in the world especially
the one
guy that got on the knee before me and
God and our families and said I will
defend and protect and love and care for
you especially
him but
nobody gets to yell and scream and curse
at me nobody gets to belittle me
especially in front of our daughter
nobody gets to teach my daughter that
this is what love and commitment and
Fidelity and marriage looks
like
period And if it happens to be the
person I married I'm done being a victim
I make the money in this house I raised
a kid in this
house behavior is a language you are
asking me with all of your big muscles
for me to
leave and I hear you loud and
clear so then the other caveat to that
is we we moved two and a half years ago
across the country so it's like what
then I consider like where where would I
go what would I do I could drive back to
my family's house then I leave my
business and everything behind like it
you know it's it's the logistics part
that's obviously the scary part and then
of course when it's when there's things
are good they're really good we have a
lot of fun we have the same interest but
yeah but you never exhale in your own
home
Nikki you never fully exhale in your own
home yeah that's
true yeah like walking on eggshell
always and when it's good you're
performing you're you're singing and
dancing and he happens to like your song
on that
day yeah that's really true yeah like as
long as I behave it that's the kind of
way it is as long as I'm what he wants
he's happy
man here's the deal there is no there's
no easy path forward for you period
every step forward is going to be
hard because you're married to somebody
that doesn't Honor doesn't love and
doesn't care for
you period so every step forward is
going to be hard being a single mom I
can't even wrap my head around how hard
that would be having to start a business
back at home where I've got Family
Resources would be unimag imaginably
hard and you've proven to yourself that
you can take care of your daughter's
needs pretty much by yourself maybe even
in spite of your husband you've proven
to yourself you can move to a new
community and make be the bread winner
of a family in just a couple of
years yeah or staying in the middle of
this
mess that's going to be hard too and I
can't make that call for
you yeah that's a good good perspective
there's no there's no path forward
that's not really challenging so I'm
going to tell you the same thing I I I I
you got to choose your heart you got to
choose your challenge here my hope is
that you choose the challenge that leads
to you being free to you being honored
and respected to you being um able to
show your daughter what strength and
respect and resilience and love and
character looks
like that's my hope but I can't make you
do
that
yeah anytime I have something very very
hard to
do a hard choice to make I always go to
my identity first and then I reverse
engineer it here's who I'm gonna
be I'm gonna be a guy that can tell the
truth I'm going to be a guy that takes
care of himself whatever the thing is
and then I have to reverse engineer the
hard things all right if I'm a guy that
take is a good Steward of his body the
one the one body God gave
me and I've got kids and I got um a
marriage and I got work that's 247
365 that means I got to work out at 4:00
in the morning sometimes that means I
got to work out at 5:30 that means today
I had to cut it quick and that mean when
I was cutting it quick I had to go real
hard like I'm going to reverse engineer
the stuff from my identity the person
I'm going to
become yeah that's a good way to put it
I it's I I feel like the I feel like the
hardest part is when you know it would
be easy if it was always bad or like my
daughter's obsessed with her dad like
she loves him so much that's the hard
like I I know you're right can I tell
something crazy nikk can I tell you
something crazy tell me yeah tell me
I've mentioned this on the show before
but it was like a lightning bolt in my
soul when I was working with a
um one of my practicum supervisors was a
guy who worked with abused
children and I remember leaving one of
the sessions one day or a conversation
we were having and I said well that
kid's going to be
okay and he looked at me and said hey
John Straight A's can be a trauma
response
to oh wow and you have fight and you
have fight and you have flee and there's
a fourth one that is is less common less
talked about there's fight fight flee
and
fawn I'm going to nuzzle up so
close that maybe they won't get me
there I'm going to be extra sexual I'm
going to be extra close I'm going to be
extra nuzzle I'm going to be extra
tender cuz like in boxing sometimes the
safest place to be to someone who hits
really hard is close as humanly possible
to
him yeah and so just because a kid
nuzzles up to their
dad doesn't mean that oh she sees how
Wonder f is no she may innately know the
safest place is real real
close that's true cuz especially after
he'll yell or whatever that's the other
thing that kills me is that I'll see
happen is for instance she'll do
something or have an outburst and he'll
get upset with her and she'll say like
she'll look at him and go do you love me
dad do you love me Dad and sometimes
like if he really she really just
frustrated him he'll just look at her
and go yeah and kind of look away and
I've had to tell him like Hey like don't
teach her that your your love is only
contingent on what she does for
you but then I guess now that I just say
that out loud that that's what happens
to me
too
yeah and I'm getting choked up now too
because I have a seven-year-old little
girl yeah so here's all I can tell you
Nikki I can't I can't I can't make you
do anything I'd love to talk to him
something went sideways in his life I
don't know what it is
I can just tell you you're worth more
than
this and for God's sakes that little
baby girl is worth more than
this and just by nature of a lot of my
higher ed work my job with college
students I'm going to put the you're
right your mom is watching you and
learning what safety looks like how to
be safe in a house with a volatile
unpredictable loud withholding
adult that's trauma by the way
trauma with a with a with a big T on it
trauma and she's watching oh this is how
we deal with this
situation
and the number of students I've sat with
over the years that have completely lost
their faith walked away from any sort of
faith it was almost never about the
faith it was about people proclaiming
one thing and then living another way
that the kids over a per perod of their
childhood could not reconcile the
cognitive distance between who this
person is espousing to be and who they
actually
are and they just say I don't I don't
know what to do with this but I'm
out because if this is what this is I'm
out and you do that for 18 years it
becomes part of your nervous system and
somebody starts talking about faith and
your body's like dude get out of here
and so we we make often make people walk
away from Faith about a about a
intellectual issue it's a nervous system
issue get me out of here this is not
safe it's the same as to your daughter
one day I love you will you marry me and
her body will say get out of here not
safe and he's getting some help he's
doing all the quote unquote right things
going to a counselor but he is not
changing his life
period and you were not put on this
planet to be his
doormat that I can't make you leave and
I can't make you have a hard
conversation and I can't make him
change I love you I love him too good
grief man there's a lot of hurt in that
house we'll be right
back this episode is sponsored by better
help hey it's toone this time of year
there can be a lot of anxiety and a lot
of drama but can can also be great but
can also be a mix of everything right
especially when it comes to giving gifts
maybe your family makes super thoughtful
handmade things or they expect you to
spend a million dollars or maybe you
just like experiencing time together or
pick up random gift cards last minute
things like gift giving can make us
bananas so no matter how hectic it gets
especially around giftgiving remember to
take care of yourself whether it's going
easier on yourself during tough moments
or having to say hey we don't have
enough money to buy all these gifts or
treating yourself to a Day of Silence
remember to give yourself some love this
holiday season and if things get too
heavy if thinking about dealing with
your family and all of the drama gets to
be too much give better help a try
better help is flexible because it's
online so it can fit into your busy
holiday schedule just fill out a short
questionnaire to get match with the
license therapist and you can switch
therapist at any time for no extra
charge in this season of Chaos in love
in sadness and all of it rolled up to
one give yourself what you need with
better help visit betterhelp.com dealone
today to get 10% off your first month
that's betterhelp
hp.com
delone all right let's go down the
street here in Nashville and talk to
Elijah what's up Elijah
hey Dr John I really appreciate you
having me you got it man what's going on
dude hey so I got married about three
weekends ago awesome I've got congrats
man thank you I got a wonderful wife um
she everything I could ask for what I
wanted to ask about today was was just
kind of a road map to one obviously how
do I not mess this up and two one of the
things we've talked about is let's make
this the best marriage of all time and
and she's on board with me on that we we
see eye to eye on on on pretty much
everything I can think of um so and I've
looked we've had premarital counseling
um I feel like we're doing the right
things but I just I just really want to
make sure that that we're doing the
right things that we need to do people
talk about putting in the work on
marriage and they don't really go past
that and explain really what that means
so just a roadmap for how we make this
the best marriage that we can dude I
love that question
and it's a disastrous goal can I can I
blow up your whole model for this yeah
you can you can blow it up all
right
100% do not seek to have the best
marriage of all time that's too much
pressure to put on both you and your
wife and your marriage that's not the
goal
okay the goal is
to ask every single day how can I love
you
today yeah and we're going to put in
some pictures of what that looks like
make no mistake AK you will mess this up
go ahead and Release Yourself from that
you'll mess it up you know what she will
too yeah and then y'all will both try to
fix it and work on it and you'll both
mess it up okay yeah so I'll give you a
couple things off top of my head that um
I wish I had known when I started also
knowing I wouldn't have done any of it
right um I I saw this recently that
before the internet we thought that
people made dumb decisions because they
didn't have the
information now we know that is not true
right yeah people have the info and they
continue to make dumb decisions so I'm
going to fill a couple things up here uh
fill you in with a couple things and um
kind of go from there okay that that
sounds great all right so the first
thing
is I want you to not try to over
intellectualize this yeah I want y'all
to make a habit a practice a daily
morning practice a daily evening
practice and then a little more of an
intensive weekly practice and then a
real intensive annual practice and that
is simply not trying to guess how she
wants to be loved yeah not try to guess
how she wants to be kept
safe not try to guess what she needs
from you or but get in a regular rhythm
of
asking yeah and the quicker you can
demystify the Hollywood bull crap that
is you're supposed to read her mind and
she's supposed to read your mind and
that's what romance is the quicker you
can melt that nonsense and be honest
with each other and begin to think of it
this way over time I'm going to teach
her how I best feel loved and vice versa
and by the way knowing every five to 10
years you're gonna change and so is she
yeah actually maybe every month or two
right yeah but so what we're doing is
we're building a framework we're not
coming up with a bunch of
answers so we're going to build a
framework where every day I'm I'm going
to ask you hey what's the best way I can
love you today what's your picture of
today look like and she might say I
don't know what kind of question is that
that means her dad her dad never asked
that question she never saw her dad ask
her mom that question she might not even
know cool we're gonna figure that out
and vice versa how can I love you today
and You' be like uh I don't know you
make out over time you'll you'll come up
with I really need just to sleep tonight
or I really need to Let's I just need to
go to something crazy can we just go out
and I know we can't afford it I know
whatever can we just go out like right
so we're going to slowly be to practice
that but if she knows you're going to
ask that question every morning and
every evening and every Sunday night
you're going to get together and go over
the calendar for the week and go over
your budget for the week dude you're
building a marriage that is so resilient
that when something happens and a whole
bunch of things will happen Elijah you
just got to trust me on this yeah both
of your parents if if if the world works
out the way it's supposed to You'll bury
all four
parents yeah you'll bury all of your
grandparents one of you will find
yourself super into somebody else you
work with or somebody else at church or
somebody else in your neighborhood and
you'll have to F claw your way
back one of you will hurt the other
person you'll have parenting difference
these things will happen this is
marriage yeah okay yeah but if every day
how can I love you today yeah yeah
that's good okay that's number one
number two be very clear about asking
your wife what does safety look like to
you
mhm you sound like a guy that's into
like how do I protect and provide right
that kind of stuff yep yep Jujitsu
working out yeah there you
go when my wife and I were dating this
is GNA shock you I'm kind of blow your
mind I was a hotthead a real hotthead
dude and then when I got into MMA and it
was less sport when I got into it it was
more just like practice was sparring and
like some sit-ups and then more sparring
um yep going hard I thought protecting
my wife was getting in a fight all the
time and what I came to realize was I
made her feel less safe on a daily basis
yeah because she didn't know if I was
going to pop off at a grocery store she
was the one that said John if you get
into some altercation in a restaurant
because somebody looked at me wrong and
you tell yourself you're protecting me
and his buddy hit you on the head with a
bottle I'm left alone with two crazed
guys you have not protected me and so I
learned with my wife that the greatest
way I could protect her was to get her
out of situations to
leave yeah and so for me courage was not
getting in the middle of a situation
courage for me was sucking up my ego and
pride and getting my wife to a safe
place bringing her
home yeah that's good does that make
sense I yeah I can definitely I can
definitely lean towards you in the first
like that guy look at you I'm going to
go get him I'm gonna I'm gonna ask him
hey what are you looking at and and so
yeah that's good and your wife will
probably say uh do you think I'm
beautiful and you'll go yeah and she'll
go he does too get over yourself right
and you'll go oh yeah right so but
that's asking the question hey when does
this make you feel safe and there's
other times um I used to joke my wife's
a Texas feminist she'd be like women
should be paid equal all this stuff
right that's all true and then she would
be like you need to go hit that dude I
was like I don't know what to do but so
there there is times that that's like
you know what I mean but that's not for
this show here's the deal communication
and asking what what to do right you
know what makes her feel safe Y what
does intimacy feel like what is sex like
like what what makes you feel loved yeah
what makes you feel all hot and bothered
what makes you just want to get it on
like not you going oh I know it's going
to be because that's the way you're you
feel or that's what you way you saw it
in some movies some sometimes like let
her dictate that and hopefully vice
versa that you open up a dialogue that
she can ask you that stuff um and that
leads to what does being loving look
like ask that question because I thought
being
loving probably the first 15 years was
making money getting a bunch of titles
getting invited to stuff getting things
autographed for my
wife
um running around in the middle of the
night with police officers and Fighters
so that I could look like I was living
some life that I really wasn't living I
wasn't in the CIA even though I was like
yeah bro I watch the shows all like all
that was me trying to love my wife come
to find out she just wanted me and I
didn't have a psychology for
that because my only value was found in
utility what can I
do and she was like he I'm smarter than
you B at the time I make the same amount
of money as you about um will you just
hold my hand and watch the sunset with
me and drink some
coffee yeah right and by the way that's
changed there's a season when you need
to go to work there's a season when like
you got to write a book and there's a
season when kids are born and need some
help like but it changes over time but
what does loving look
like yeah that's good I'm I'm gearing up
for a time where I'm gonna have to have
to work really hard for about two to
three years for my career and getting
that started perfect and and knowing
knowing that communication is going to
be you know the biggest say asking how
can I love you how can I make you feel
safe those questions that's I'm sure
that's going to be really important that
time and I here's a a magic question for
every marriage I think every person
that's married or about to be married
should ask this question what do we want
our home to feel
like yeah and then let's reverse
engineer that and in my house I wanted
it full of laughter I wanted it to feel
warm when I walked in and so we had to
figure that out well John if you want
the house to feel warm I need you to put
your dishes up the night
before yep John I need you to help make
the bed I need you to help with the kids
in the morning and so then when you get
home ah right awesome let's do that
relax yeah U and here's a couple of
other things that are marriage
adjacent you take care of
you all the way around not just lifting
weights and going to Jiu-Jitsu make sure
you got a group of men that you talk to
on the
regular that you tell this stuff that
makes you scared dude I'm scared about
like my
job yeah I am like this woman that I
work with she thinks I'm hilarious and
like I'm kind of starting to like think
of a joke that I can tell her when I get
to work like dude and you got to have
people that you talk to yeah okay yeah
that's good um and the third like go see
a counselor man if you're about to gear
up and go get it get yourself a coach
get yourself a counselor that you can so
that way you don't use your wife as a
trash can over the next three years that
she only gets you when you're exhausted
and you're not going to believe what
happened today right
yep and then here's the last one hold
all of us with a really open
hand the greatest quote I've ever heard
about marriage was from EST Perell when
she said most adults have four or five
great passionate loves in their
adulthood and if they work really hard
it can be with the same
person I've been married for 21 and a
half years I'm a radically different
person than I was 5 years ago
unrecognizable I am radically different
from the guy I was 10 years ago
literally
unrecognizable and the guy that got
married when he was 24 I don't even that
dude jeez that guy needs to be taken out
behind the Woodshed and just beat right
and so I tell you she's gonna change and
so are
you and that's not the problem that's
the
beauty yeah that's good so if you hold
her to a list of you said you believe in
this dude the greatest thing is changing
our beliefs it's one of my favorite
things in the world to do that's why I
read books why I listen to podcasts
that's why I have interviews that's why
I travel the country Oh I thought I
believed this I thought something
different you and your wife need to be
really secure on your values and hold
your beliefs super super lightly so me
and my wife Ser some values dignity and
respect no matter
what curiosity over
everything um uh
Hospitality right so if she comes in and
goes hey I don't think I believe X
anymore I believe y
now then our value is not you will
believe exactly like me it is curiosity
and dignity whoa dude that sounds wild
tell me about that right yeah that's
different than you can't tell our kids
that our kids are gonna be fine you see
what I'm saying so maybe a fun like
month do this brother have a one-month
anniversary she she'll never see it
coming have a one month anniversary and
uh take her out and have something
really nice where y'all can write down
your values who are we going to be and
make sure you talk through I know our
beliefs are going to change you're going
to read a book you're going to have an
experience you're going to get fired I'm
going to get fired we're going to have
changes in what we believe that's the
beauty of our life the only people who
can't figure that crap out are
politicians Cheez Louise we're going to
get new information cool that's awesome
what are our values going to be who are
we going to
be and let's ink those in right now and
then let's hold some beliefs really
Loosely I'm going to send you um all of
the questions for humans cards both
decks for couples and the Christmas one
that is probably going to be sold out by
the time the show comes out and I'm
going to send you a couple other
questions for humans decks and building
an unanxious life I want you all to read
that book together and just build the
road map in your house as yall are
you're saying okay the next three years
I'm going to be grinding it in my job
which is Amazing by the way
um I've had multiple two or three or
four years stint when I'm grinding it
grinding it at work um use that as a
road map how are we both going to be
whole in our house it's going to be
awesome I'm proud of you man great
questions to be asking I waited till
you're 15 to ask these questions so dude
you're way ahead of the game take care
good man we'll be right
back hey guys it's delone listen as the
holidays get closer and things get more
chaotic and finances get tighter and
family members get louder and louder
opinions about
everything you can find peace with
hallow the number one Christian Prayer
app in the world and even if you're not
Christian I promise you'll find Value in
stopping slowing down and praying to a
higher power listening to the prayers
spoken by other people Hall has
thousands of Christmas and Advent
prayers and meditations plus incredible
peaceful holiday music to help you
d-stress some of the music I even listen
to while I'm lifting in my garage you
can join in Hallow's pre 25 challenge
with daily devotions based on the
writings of CS Lewis meditate with
scripture read by Jonathan roomy from
the TV show chosen or wind down to a
Christmas Bible story so find your sense
of calm and peace and get hallow free
for three months at hall.com
dealone that's three months free at
hall.com
dealone
all right let's go out to the concrete
jungles where dreams are made of to New
York and talk to Monica what's up
Monica hi Dr bone thank you for speaking
with me of course thank you for calling
what's
up um well my question is I'm like in my
mid 50s maybe late 50s and uh that was
awesome I'm 42 and by 42 I mean like 61
that was awesome um and I just you know
my life is sort of pathetic and I don't
really know what to do next like I don't
know how to fix it or what to do um how
hold on hold on you can't just drop that
challenge and leave old man that's from
K kid one all right so Define pathetic
for me give me a couple of data points
that suggest Monica my new friend is
pathetic I got a pen I'm writing these
down let's do
it um you know I'm 56 years old I'm not
married I don't have kids
hold on hold on neither of those things
count so continue that doesn't make you
pathetic it makes you single so go
ahead you know I just sort of have like
made I'm really nervous I'm sorry um
don't be nervous you're my friend we're
just have
nachos I've made like a whole bunch of
like bad decisions like way back you
know I like I messed up my like 20s by
like just getting high and drinking um
and then got sober and then sort of like
hold can I can can I just keep
interrupting you is that okay sure okay
I know it makes hard for our audience to
listen but I just want to stop you as
we're going okay if we were in
counseling I'd let you spend all these
out and we'd pull each one of these
apart but I just want to stop you
here what in your
20s
um what in your 20s doing drugs and
drinking was your body trying to protect
you from that you grew up 0er through
19 um I mean I had some you know I mean
overall I had a great
childhood I call I call bull crap on
that um H
dick you know I had like a bunch of
years where like an older family member
did like some really messed up stuff
with me sexually so I think I you know
there was that stuff that I was trying
to Monica deal with
Monica
for 10
years your body was trying to protect
you in the only way it knew
how you didn't waste anything you
survived yeah if there was a shipwreck
in the middle of the
ocean and you got hit on the head as the
boat went down and you floated and
treaded
water and EV EV somebody picked you
up or eventually the waves brought you
to
shore would anybody say wow you sure
wasted an opportunity to swim real
hard no they would say thank God you're
alive right now is there better ways to
handle childhood sexual
abuse on paper yes there
is did you
survive
yeah yeah you did yeah you
did yeah I mean you know I'm definitely
one of those people who believe you know
getting high probably saved my life I
probably would have killed myself if I
didn't so I mean that's that's that's
the that's only somebody who truly
understands addiction can say that and
hear it and I'm with you okay high five
you thank you um so yeah so like you
know that was my 20s and
then I mean I never left I mean I'm in
AA I never left but I didn't stay sober
that whole time um but it's just been
like a series of like bad decisions you
give me some more give me what was the
bad decision in your
30s um just like relapsing you know like
not staying sober and trying to deal
with my past and not really trusting
anyone to be able to tell anyone the
truth so like it just sort of wasted a
lot of years
um and I don't know like going to dead
end jobs when I could have done
something else but I was basically too
afraid cuz I just I just sort of got
stuck in like these jobs that I thought
there was a future and there wasn't a
future Monica somebody who was your
family the One Tribe on planet Earth
that's supposed to love you and keep you
safe hurt you in one of the most
powerful and destructive ways a person
can hurt somebody else
and that never should have
happened I'm I'm just sick and so sorry
that that
happened and I'm so sick and sad that
you didn't have an environment in your
home where it was okay to say
something yeah that it was not okay
that's not yeah and so don't come here
not telling the full truth my childhood
was was great it wasn't it was
hell and what made it worse is that you
were burning alive inside your own skin
and you had to keep a smile on that face
and make sure the house was
okay yeah and so I want you to be real
real nice to 20 and 30 year old
Monica because everything this wasn't an
intellectual exercise for you your body
said no one can be
trusted yeah you got to figure this out
on your
own right yeah I mean it was yeah I mean
it wasn't until I mean you know I'm
sober a long time now um how
long uh in January it'll be 20
years so you know it's been a long time
now straight gangster
Monica thank you all right so you got
sober at 36 tell me about your 40s
um I just sort of you I mean I went to
therapy I did like you know EMDR like
did all that stuff and but I got badly
into debt you know like I just sort of
you know I gained a ton of weight
and um I guess I kind of like hid out in
AA because I didn't know know what else
to do you know and
um yeah I just you know like I stated a
job that I thought there was a future
and then that like imploded did a few
years ago
um and it just been like one bad
decision like you know like getting to
debt getting out of debt and now like
I'm back in debt you know like I I lost
like you know I finally lost the weight
like I lost um over Co like right right
after covid I lost like 75 pounds and
now I've gained 10 pounds back and it's
like you know like I'm just like I feel
like I just can't seem to I can't get it
together you know like I I can't de you
know like I just here's here's the
fundamental here's the fundamental
thing you think Monica's
broken you don't like
Monica
yeah think about this if you had a car
that you were pretty sure wouldn't run
right and that was pretty sure was
really
ugly you would never drive it unless you
absolutely had to you would take a taxi
you'd call an Uber you take the bus you
take the you take the
train yeah you'd avoid that
car how in the world can somebody love
you Monica when you won't love
you right how in the world can somebody
I don't know how to change that do what
I don't know how to change that you've
got to let 20-year-old Monica
go she fought like hell for
you she had a really weird way of
punching and kicking but she kept
fighting and 30-year-old Monica for
about half that decade fought and kicked
and probably started crashing and
burning and 36- year- old Monica did the
hardest thing Monica's ever had to do
which is get rid of that crutch because
the thing that kept you alive in your
20s was going to kill you in your
30s m
and then you eak out trust with a
employer and they burned you and your
body was like told you quit trusting
right
yeah yeah and on the marathon of life
you walked your 40s you just said I'm
not gonna I'm gonna quit sprinting and
running and stopping and crashing I'm
gonna walk cool here we
are nothing you have told me is
pathetic not one thing is pathetic do I
wish it had played out differently for
you starting with child abuse starting
with um a home where you were a window
ornament and a air freshener for your
family
yes I wish with all my guts it had been
different and it
wasn't and yeah do I wish that kind of
trauma hadn't sent you on a 30-year
journey of trying to figure out how to
stay alive I do with all my guts and
here we
are yeah I just like I don't know what
to do I don't know what I just don't
know what to do you know like my mom is
85 and like in the last six months it
sort of hit me like oh God like I could
easily have another 30 years of this oh
you got 30 years
easy you're too strong you're too strong
and so the question before you is this I
mentioned this in a previous call and I
I wrote wrote a whole chapter on this in
a
book The Path before
you has two
paths both of them
suck they do they're both gonna be hard
you trying to White Knuckle sobriety
alone and work dead end jobs in a really
expensive place to live it's going to be
very
hard very very
hard you spinning some
time forgiving Monica and celebrating
Monica for keeping you
alive learning to trust again when every
single cell in your body is going to
tell you not to that's going to be
hard not losing weight because you don't
like Monica and you think Monica's gross
but losing weight and staying a good
Steward of your body because Monica's
freaking awesome and she deserves to
feel good when she wakes up it's going
to be
hard
getting out of debt not because I'm such
a freaking pathetic bum and I keep
borrowing no not owing anybody any money
because For the first time in my life
nobody's gonna own
Monica I'm gonna walk down the street
with my head held
high yeah see what I'm
saying
yeah yeah it seems I don't know it's h
yeah here here's the here's the truth
and here's how I know I'm not just I'm
not not just spitting bull craap at you
have you heard the story of my
mom no my mom wasn't allowed to go to
college she grew up in a religious group
that wouldn't allow her to go to
college my dad always told her to go the
kid my brother and sister and I we
always cheered her on at the age of 42
she finally got a job I mean she finally
went to her first Community College
Class
42 I was in high school I think my
sister was a fresh college and I had a
little brother she took one class next
semester she took one more class next
semester she took one more
class at 57 she graduated with her
PhD wow this year I think she's 73 or 74
I'm not a great son she spent her last
summer at Oxford in London or outside of
London teaching students
in her
70s she would not get on a plane in her
40s wouldn't get on
it and so I not only is this like you're
worth more I'm not just throwing
Instagram quotes at you I've seen it in
my
house wow okay
okay the question I have for you is are
you willing to not try to find love not
try to find a job are you willing to put
the work in to love
Monica yeah I just don't know I don't
know how people do that like I don't get
it I got you are you
in yeah all right here's I'm gonna give
you a bunch of stuff to get you started
and then you're going to owe me a couple
of homework assignments is that a fair
trade yeah sure all right so gift number
one I'm giving you own your past change
your future my number one bestselling
book on I'm going give to you for free
it's about trauma I want you to read it
and it's the more importantly than the
descriptions of trauma is the back end
which is what do I do
now what are the exercises what are the
things I need to do
okay a lot of therapy is a lot of
talking and talking is important but
also you have to go go act you have to
go do something different and it's time
for you to do something different fair
enough yeah all right you're going to
read that book and then I'm going to
give you my most recent bestselling book
building a non-anxious life and it's a
road map to living a life where you can
your body can finally
go so then when that guy offers you a
job you can go dude I'm not working for
you I can see this now or when that guy
ask you for coffee you can go yeah my
body thinks he's safe I'm
in Okay the third thing I'm going to
send you all of financial piece
university for
free all the videos all everything okay
okay all nine
lessons and I'm going to send you the
best app on planet Earth for budgeting
every dollar app for a year for
free and it automatically links to your
bank and and when you spend something it
lets you know and it teaches you how to
budget and walks it all the way through
it okay okay the next thing I'm going to
send you for free is I'm going to send
you um two sessions with a financial
coach here at Ramsey Solutions where I
work and they're going to talk through
your actual numbers
okay okay and help you get they're going
to walk alongside you and help you build
a budget and 56y old Monica is going to
go it's so stupid I don't have to build
a budget dude everybody needs help it's
all good mhm okay okay yeah the next
thing I'm going to give
you is my friend Ken Coleman's book for
paycheck to
purpose we're going to help you get a
job I'm also going to send you his get
clear assessment which is an assessment
which is like all right I'm 56 what the
heck do I want to do for the next 30
Years yeah okay uhuh I got you all those
tools here's what you owe me thank you
all right I don't know it's probably a
thousand dollars and more worth of stuff
here's what here's what um you owe
me you owe me a promise that before the
weekend is over you're going to write a
letter to 24y Old
Monica and that letter is going to start
with dear Monica thank you so much for
keeping me
alive and I want you to go down memory
lane remember that one
time I cannot believe you did that what
were you thinking
I can't believe you got in that car and
you went to that place and you made that
deal and you end up in that hospital you
ended up with those
guys yeah and you were doing whatever
you had to do to keep me alive thank
you okay and then you're going to write
a letter to 30-year-old Monica the one
that decided I'm goingon to go get
sober and you're going to tell her thank
you for entering into the pit of Hell
yet again this time without a sword and
without a
shield because the Sword and the shield
for a long time was alcohol and drugs
and she went back in with nothing just
AA and then I want you to write 56y old
Monica a
letter and that letter is going to be
you talking to yourself and it's going
to start dear Monica I love
you so glad you're still
here
here's who we're going to become are you
ever going to be a millionaire probably
not are you ever going to own a 5,000
foot house probably
not so let's don't be S let's don't like
you know what I'm saying like let's
don't project this like I'm gonna
manifest what no let's don't do that if
you become a millionaire I'll cheer you
on dude I'll be so
happy right here's what I want for you I
want you to look up and be
80 and have a small condo that you own
it's yours all by yourself nobody owns
it or maybe even a small
house I don't want you to have a little
bit of retirement and Social Security I
don't want you to have a car that is a
good running car that you own
completely oh you have a small
retirement you see what I'm saying want
you to begin to paint that picture are
you going to have a Rolls-Royce out
there no are you going to have a paid
for Camry or Corolla yes
if you have a paid for Corolla at the
age of 62 I promise that car is still
going before long after you are right
because those cars never stop
running right but here's what we're
grieving the picture we're grieving the
I thought it was G it's not and here's
what it is going to look
like and at 62 you might be a
teacher you might be a businesswoman you
might be a small business owner I don't
know what you're going to be
be but you're going to have your head
held high you're going to be
proud you're going to be knocking these
things out you're going to have some
friends that come over to your
house some weird wacka dooodle Doo
friends that come over to Monica's house
and hang
out
because you love
them
you
Monica this is the your Independence Day
Monica's free starting today you've been
sober for 20 years game
on I just put all the chips in all of
them I call Monica you're move we'll be
right
back hey what's up deloney here listen
you and me and everybody else of the
planet has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
my new book building a non- anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful nonanxious
life get your copy today at john.com
all right as we wrap up today's show um
the editor staff youall aren't going to
hear it but I went to say um I put all
my chips on the table to the last caller
and also at the same time the other side
of my brain was like let's say we moved
our chips all in and put and
move came out of my mouth I pooped I
didn't
poo but they edited it out so yall can't
hear it but thought to let you know what
happened gosh our editor staff is
amazing all right so as we wrap up
today's show um this is a great article
by Lucy Hanley from CNBC uh I've
actually been experimenting with some of
this stuff in my house and it's magic so
um according to to psychologist the
questions how was school and how is your
day are not the best questions to ask
children after a day of school children
quickly understand when adults are
trying to get an answer from them and
not trying to engage them and so really
quick how's your day
fine um how was school good like they
become automated they become a part of
your
kit so very wide ranging questions are
so big they it's just easier to say yeah
it was fine and most adults want to
switch off after work and let go of
their day children are the same and I
find myself how was work today and I go
fine it was cool their mind needs a
break and often their main focus is on
food fun play and rest said Dr Martha
deos sco so it's such a common question
kids just let it roll off so here's a
couple of things what to say right after
school
don't turn the first second of school
into a 50 questions how's your day
what's going on how's it let them get in
your car and go let them walk into your
house after being on the bus and go or
you come home from work and they've
already been at home for a while let's
let them walk in and hey how's it going
feel your energy you feel theirs be
patient and wait till your child is
ready to talk um she said then when you
ask questions be very specific some
questions I've started asking in my
house who did you help today I just
popped that question off I saw it on the
internets I asked my kids my son who's a
middle schooler of course answered me I
helped me and I was like that's the
wrong person and he goes I'm pretty good
and I help anyway my daughter though
thought about it for a second she's an
elementary school
person kid and she rattled off a couple
people she helped if ID said how was
school she never would have mentioned
that but one kid dropped a bunch of
stuff and she helped that person and
then another kid was got in trouble at
scho at lunch and she went with that was
pretty neat just to say hey who'd you
help today so I'm starting to ask that
question more and more um and hopefully
they begin to look in their day for who
can I help other questions that the
article suggests is what did you enjoy
most about playtime or lunch today
what's the funniest thing that happened
at lunch today what's the worst thing
that happened at lunch that's how I
found out one of my kids got another
silent lunch schools stop with the
silent lunches it's ridiculous let kids
talk and be loud and be silly and be
kids why let me think about it cuz
they're kids and they have to sit in
your classrooms and stare at a stupid
Chromebook or do homework all day long
or watch KH Academy videos even though
taxpayers are paying your salary or just
do worksheets let them laugh at lunch
for God's sake all right I'm off my soap
box now uh what did a teacher our
friends say today that made you laugh
that made you
nervous it's also important to talk
about emotions were you feeling sad
today was there anything that made you
feel better today was there a time you
felt lonely what' you do about it here's
the thing ask very specific questions
give them a second to
answer maybe you go first I felt lonely
today when Kelly came in a meeting and
just stared at me and shook her head and
embarrassment and shame and walked out I
felt lonely what did I do yeah I just
shoved my face full of candy to try to
make all the sadness go
away did you feel lonely today that
might be a conversation you could ask if
you worked with
K so here's what I'm saying wait till
your kids are ready to talk maybe you go
first don't ask broad questions like how
is the world how's
today be very very specific and ask
emotional questions what's the what's
the thing that made you feel awesome
today made you feel
scared and let's create a new dialogue
with our kids let's model for them what
that looks like and maybe you do that
with your husband or with your wife
model what that looks like so that they
have a picture of what it looks like
when you ask
them let's ask questions to listen to
our kids not just to do a
checklist all right y'all stay in school
don't do drugs be nice to each other
Kelly you're getting better at this
directing job producing
job I work with what I'm
given
bye